uh let's start today welcome to the
fourth day good morning and today
christian will be telling us about local
week 2013
okay
so good morning everybody thanks for
getting upset early
so i will talk about
local convergence for sparse graphs it's
another notion of convergence and it's
um
i think originally ramco founder hofstra
who has sort of almost written whole
book about it was supposed to talk about
it and then uh he couldn't come and i
said fine i'll talk about it but it has
a lot of it has been mentioned jaganev
will use it in her talk this afternoon
so this will
i doubt i will use our enter half okay
so we'll see but because so you can ask
as many questions as you want because
i have a few slides i
can use to relate this back to what it
would be compared to dense graph
convergence but we don't really need
that part so if we just
finish with the stuff i'm doing on the
whiteboard because you have tons of
questions that's just fine
okay so but before i do the whiteboard
just as sort of context
so we still are wondering when should we
consider a sequence of graph convergence
and we have seen that for dense graphs
there are many equivalent notions
and so the question is what do we want
to do if we have sparse graph
such that the average degree is bounded
okay
and
so
it turns out that if you just take the
notions for dense graphs and just look
at them as they are
they will all be trivial okay so let me
give you an example so if we sample for
example two vertices is uniformly at
random
from a graph whose average degree is
bounded
well you see the probability of seeing
two vertices is the sum of the vertices
the probability that the edge is there
so this will be twice the number of
edges normalized
and so you get one over n
d n bar
going to zero
and actually this is true if you do it
like that for any sparsity okay so you
certainly have to
modify these you could just divide this
probability by something else but then
it's not a probability anymore and that
would actually not work okay so this is
this is the one quantity which you
really can't that easily fix the other
ones there's some fixes and they
sometimes work and they sometimes don't
work
but
um
we would like to have some notion of
sampling right because there was this
very nice thing for dense graphs as i
sample k vertices
i find sort of a k vertex graph i can
then first do my limit as the graph
sequence goes to infinity and then the
limit k goes to infinity i get an
infinite random graph so that's a very
nice limit okay so if we for the moment
forget that they're graph ones if we try
to express
sort of a limit of a finite graph you
might just say natural look a limit of a
final graph should be an infinite graph
well that is not quite true so in the
dense setting we saw it's an infinite
graph but it's actually an infinite
random graph
so is there some way to do something
similar here
and actually before we came up with this
theory of graph convergence um
a person sitting next in my office
actually had done that before and we
actually were not aware of it but we
actually were aware of it we were just
too stupid to put it together but anyhow
it's we were doing the theory for dense
graphics it doesn't apply but any other
triangle together with ether benjamini
they actually defined the notion of
graph convergence for bounded degree
graphs they actually had to photograph
this
bounded degree period
but it actually works much more
generally it will certainly for average
bounded degrees under some conditions
which i will not go into for the moment
but they just said okay so rather than
sampling many vertices and look at the
induced subgraph just sample one vertex
look at a given radius r
see what you see okay so you see some
random graph
some random rooted graph
and therefore the limit will be an
infinite possibly infinite rooted random
graph
okay so
we have this sequence which is locally
convergent or benjamin ishram convergent
aldous had some implicit version of it
so as in many of these cases aldo sort
of solved the mass problem before any of
us thought about it but he didn't
formulate the concept this is another
example of that so the concept is really
due to benjamini schwem but a lot of the
mars you might want to need is already
in ivor's who however it was more
implicit in that
so who is the person who is in the
office next to you
oh that's sure
okay and
he actually did that just as he came to
microsoft and we were hiring him so he
even gave a job interview talk about it
um yes
so you want to solve the sparse graph
where the adjust the number of edges is
small
and square linear then actually in this
talk i will just do linear in linear
jennifer on friday will do when it's
growing with n but smaller
i see so at this top we do linearity
if it's linear can you just multiply
that
like that in the limits by n
so
you could but you end up with a problem
because for example assume we would
count
if if i have something like counting
triangles okay
let's say we do g and p
okay in g and p if p is constant over n
then the number of z
is just
n to the
3 times p2 this 3 which is c to the 3.
okay
so the probability so you have to so if
you translate it into a probability you
can normalize in such a way that this
becomes of order one okay but you have
an issue because if you look at this guy
what's the number of edges okay the
number of edges
is p times c
so that's of the same order
this is c okay
and so
actually if c is larger than one c
smaller so
in certain
so
you're hiding all the cluster but
nevertheless the number of edges c times
n
oh okay so the problem is here is
actually the problem okay so the number
of triangle is c to the power three
the number of edges is c times n
so what does that mean which means by
just deleting a tiny fraction of the
edges
your triangle count suddenly goes to
zero
okay
and if you just divide in this quantity
which i had there by the by what you
think you should divide
okay
this problem will bite you in the back
it will be extremely unstable you will
get a notion of convergence where if i
remove three edges i have a different
limit
which is probably not what you want
okay so that just doesn't work
and the other version actually does work
so and i will will so i will go on on
the board so if you didn't get the
definition i'll do that again so i will
give you a few examples
i will in this case actually we have
never talked about random graphs
actually if you have or not very
explicitly so all my notions of
convergence you would have to
invent what they mean for random graphs
because now actually your sequence is
random and for example if i sample k
random vertices now i have two
randomness how do i deal with both of
them and if you don't do sampling
convergence if you count sub graphs and
so on it's a little easier because well
you get some random quantity but you you
don't have another randomness you could
get confused about
and so then you can just say okay i have
this quantity and that quantity
converges in probability or almost
surely and we need to do something like
that here but we have to be very careful
because there is this randomness from
sampling and there might be underlying
randomness from the graph
and if you don't sort of deal with them
correctly then you can not prove no
theorems okay
so that's a little tricky and i will
discuss it
then there is it turns out a property so
when we did this sampling k vertices we
did the limit we got an infinite random
graph and had a very nice symmetry it
was exchangeable okay and that gave us
some representations here in either
hoover and that could do a lot with the
symmetry so the question is is there
some symmetry here and it turns out the
answer is yes
it's uni
unimodularity
and
then
for for graph fonts we had this theorem
which says given a graph and i can
always find a sequence which converges
to it
so now you may ask if given a
unimodularity limit which i haven't yet
defined for you does there exist a
sequence of graph convergence to it
and that actually
well if you are sort of
not sure you're getting tenure and you
solve this problem then no matter how
bad you were before you'll get tenure
okay because that's a wide open problem
i mean there's some partial results but
it's really
open since
since at least 20 years and even the
famous aldous wrote a paper which she
had to attract because he claimed it's
true and it's not true so so there are
sort of
proofs which are wrong and we don't we
just don't notice it okay so i will do
these on the
whiteboard
and i might actually use the whole
whiteboard so can we for the moment
i might even want to use the middle okay
so
okay so to make actually what i said
before really precise we need a little
bit of notation because it turns out
that in this setting it's really
important to think about
but if i have a rooted random graph and
i say something is equal to this
glutamine graph we don't really have
equal we have
uh
being isomet
easing uh iso
isomorphic too um
and we have to do that carefully okay so
let me first discuss sort of the
symmetries we have here okay so we have
standard isomorphism
but i will actually need to discuss
whole thing is
space
rooted
totally fine
and we need a little bit of structure on
this graph to define this notion of
convergence so in particular we need to
discuss what is an isomorphism so i have
a graph
it's locally finite
i mean by that
locally finite means that all degrees
are finite
but they're not bounded the graph can be
infinite it can look very complicated
infinite graph but if you look at and it
has a root okay
so that is root
okay so now we have a rooted locally
finite possibly infinite graph
okay
and now
i will say that
sigma g
let me just write
g
and
i'll just give the root no one let me
call it o prime g prime okay
they're isomorphic if
this is the projection
file
this is what is set to the vertex set
and now
and
two properties one
is the usual one
g
if
okay
any idea what my second condition will
be not from the experts
those who know the definition of local
weak convergence are not allowed to
answer does anybody not know this
definition
okay so do you have a guess what my
second condition would be
so we should send the root to the root
okay so
phi of the
root
okay
so
um when i sort of just on wrote on my
slides that the local neighborhoods
converge i mean that they converge
if you sort of mod out by
okay
now it turns out that it's often where i
will want to talk about continuous
functions so it's actually
yes this is a definition
same here this says set
okay and then
we say that
sigma
g
is
isomorphic
okay
so
um
can i move this one too
oh and now i can write the wall
good
so now i need a second notion the notion
of the ball of radius r rounded point i
think i will not define that so if you
have a graph you get a graph distance
and the ball of radius r
is consists of the set of all vertices
up to that distance and all the edges
will join vertices
up to that distance
so
now i will say
now i will define the distance and it's
called the local distance
graphs
and i will just give the roots the same
in the interest
otherwise you just need to do this math
lazy involved
okay so this is
the infimum
of
numbers
such that
all of wages are
in
one of the
graphs sigma g
is isomorphic to the ball of radius r
okay
so
so now you may
okay so so why is it maybe a good idea
well you know that is infinite graphs
and i want to say well if they're up to
some large neighborhood around the
origin
it's the same up to isomorphisms
it's hard to tell them apart i have to
walk for a long time
and if you imagine having some process
on it the process have to go pretty far
so it might be sense to define those as
near to each other and that's what this
does
um
and you might think that
us so that probably means that if the
distance is zero
then
these two graphs
must be isomorphic
okay
that's actually not the case can
somebody imagine why that's not the case
measure dr
so what of br is a ball of radius r
so this
set of x
g
so this depends on the graph
such that the graph distance
and then we look at the induced subgraph
here's a large graph
here's another large graph
and now
the ball of radius one
so the ball of radius two
is all these vertices
for you
including the boundary okay so this is
the vertex set
and this graph
and this visits root
you're not like embedding this
2d space you just happen to draw a
differential just above the graph
okay so just yes some graph i check that
all of radius are in the graph so that's
all verges you can reach by walk of
length up to r
and then you look at the edges you see
up to that distance
and you throw out the rest
okay
and now here i have another graph
this looks like this
okay
and now if i look just up to this
distance
if i look up one distance more
they actually
the distance now they are not equal but
they're still isomorphic
but if now
i make this one look like that and this
might look like that then if you go up
to one distance more you see that this
grass now has this other trigger here in
this windows
okay so then for these two graphs the
distance therefore so the minimum are
the largest are where they're different
where they're equal
is one two
so that is this
okay is that clear so far
okay
it doesn't really matter that have put
your one over out this
i just want something such that okay but
all right but inverse to the emboss
or reciprocal something that is right
however
this is not does not mean they're
necessary isomorphic now so let's do
this again okay
so far as i look isomorphic okay
if the distance is so this distance is
actually one over infinity so let's see
okay but now i add something to this
graph
just
do we always start from the root
you always have to start from
okay it's a ball of radius r around the
root
to look okay so that's why it's called
the local
okay
so the distance between two rooted
graphs
essentially tells you
roughly up to which distance in the
graph metrics
is now
this class
if i calculate these faults of radius r
this guy is never entered
so
with this distance i still have distance
0 okay
so this will actually only give you
equality
for the component of scotch
okay
so we could actually just define this
space as
rooted connected graphs and actually you
might want to think about it like that
even though sometimes it's convenient to
have these other graphs too but just put
them all into one it sort of doesn't
matter if it's a disconnected components
we will consider them the same because
we will think in this metric
and so you might as well choose the
connected representative
um so think of them as connect okay so
if
we in addition say locally find it
connected to us
okay
then actually they are isomorphic
if and only if this distance is c
okay so now we have a nice space we have
the space of rooted possibly infinite
graphs
and we know when they are sort of the
same i.e isomorphic
and we have met with sized in sort of
the words of the
don't know i don't know topologist
this
uh
yes
when you say connect
connected for these graphs can there be
a difference between a
path notion of connectedness and the
you know topological
disconnect because you can imagine you
can imagine a connected graph where
their
parts so far away
but i guess in this definition so should
i worry about that distinction or does
it not
because there is always sort of okay if
they're infinitely far away
um
then sort of i don't quite even know
what it means okay so because it's in a
topological notion you should think
about how we sort of generate our
topologies
and we always want to think about the
product topology or something like that
so
so there's no i never i mean
this is sort of all the trick with all
probability theorem infinite graphs
right you sort of effectively always say
whatever i define i generate
by my finite objects even the sigma
algebraic infinity in calculation will
be
if there's nothing you can define by
something which is infinitely erased
this notion doesn't exist
and in the d we don't have infinite
array we just have larger larger balls
we sort of look at them so um
so you don't have to worry about that
okay
so now we have this notion of
of our topology
okay
and now we can just say okay so whenever
i write this g now this is this
object
i will sometimes write g
d local
and i will
sometimes think of this as
where i
factor out
equivalence classes disrespectfully
local so you always should think of but
we see now if i factor this out this is
just the same as looking as equivalence
classes of infinite rooted random groups
so
two isomorphic infinite rooted random
graphs are considered the same
okay so now we have a nice space and
it's sort of very intuitively so it's
it's very near to your intuition we just
want this local neighborhoods converge
for each hour and that is captured by
that except you have to look at
isomorphisms
so it doesn't matter okay as long as it
goes to zero as r goes to infinity and
it's smaller term i don't care
okay good
so um
this is now for random graphs
not yet
not yet right so in the bottom line
you're saying that
graphs are
i'm saying i will sometimes write this
and i will sometimes write this and i
will know i'm just you always should
think of this rooted infinite graph if i
talk if i will talk about the continuous
function on this set of graphs
the suspect is next
so if this thing holds for all r are the
two graphs like so morphic i guess
they're yes so they're isomorphic
exactly if and only if
this holds
if you restrict yourself on the
component the root is contained in
whatever you can
do that but if you sort of in the end
factor out by this equivalence
then actually
all graphs which have the same connected
component of the roofs are considered
the same anyhow
so i may as well right i'm only on the
graph i mean i'm i'm at the root i'm
walking around the fact that they're
here is another quantum universe i don't
see i don't know
okay
this means the aliens but they never
come to me and i never see them they
never see me
so this part i just don't care
that will be important eventually
because if you for example have this
infinite
rooted graph and now you do calculation
of it
then you might again get disconnected
components
and you have to throw them out
so so this little issue is sort of i
didn't draw it just to confuse you
because
maybe there was originally a connection
here
and this thing was really distinguishing
the two graphs but now you do
percolation and this piece is
disconnected
and these others are still infinite and
now they look safe
so now
we still have no randomness okay that
for the moment
a sequence
not necessarily okay
possibly
disconnected deterministic course
okay so let me draw a few first
i will take
how many triangles okay so gn
three
triangles that's not
so that's one thing you could think of
the other one
would be
a little piece of the infinite square
letters
okay so this will be
silence
maybe
it's
the side
chunk of your word
but in addition
so this is now in the language of
physicist the cubic centered letters
and now what i do is so i have so
imagine your favorite deterministic
sequence of graphs
and for finite graphs
um
but whose number of vertices is goes to
infinity
so now
i will
choose
a root o n
uniformly attracted
so what does that give me can you still
read it down here
so this gives me now
a rooted
random graph
okay
so this is
okay if i fix this is just an element of
my possibly infinite booted
random graphs
um
so this is an example right so if i put
a point here
you get some
rooted graph it's not infinite
if you put a point
somewhere here you get a different
rooted random graph pretty soon as soon
as the distance is larger than one
if you choose this as your root
you get another
rooted random graph
okay
and
so if pn
is a distribution
okay so this is just a uniform
distribution over your vertices
then
i would say definition
gn
smoking
if and only
this is the measure mu
over
power space of infinite rooted random
graphs
such that
the expectation
with respect to there's no randomness
except for the randomness you put on by
looking at a random root
so the expectation with respect to this
randomness
of any function
of your
graph okay
so this could be for example sorry
continuous no any continuous
i haven't yet set for all f okay so for
all f comes
such that okay so
just for the moment we define this for
any function okay so this
should converge to the expectation with
respect to mu
if you calculate this function on
should be drawn from that distribution
so let's see okay for all
f
from your set of if possibly infinite
rooted random graph into r
bounded
okay
so roughly speaking this
you can just think of the function f as
only depending on balls of a certain
radius r
but you should allow this radius to
possibly grow to infinity yes
does the limit exist so
that is my definition
it's considered locally weak convergent
if there exists
a new world such that this horse
so
let's see what that means
in these examples okay so what do these
examples converge
this example
yes is it true that for finite and the
graph it should define it
for deterministic
graphs
okay
so we have a growing sequence of fine
yes you need final graph because
otherwise i wouldn't know what the
uniform random purchases
okay
so
let's look at these examples
question before can i ask you a quick
question for motivation yes
what kinds of
once we have the definition what's the
best what's like the killer app of the
application of the definition okay so
let me
step back this before i should probably
have done that before
so this notion of local be convergent is
okay is a way to define the limit of
sparse graphs
okay
and it turns out that
so so weak
hinted to that in his talk okay so if
you have a sequence which is locally
convergent
maybe his limit is a tree
okay
or maybe the limit is a random object a
branching process
okay and now you might
hope that your sequence of graphs
is
well so if this sequence is actually
deterministic okay
it's not very useful unless you start to
study processes on it okay
if you don't study processes on it
it's still useful but then it's only
useful if you have random graphs so
assume i have some sequence of random
graphs like gnp
okay and i wonder does this sequence
have a giant component
and to decide that it turns out that he
gave us a criterion which he didn't
define which was and which i haven't
defined yet because i haven't defined
for you yet what we do when the sequence
is random but when the sequence is
random you could ask is there a giant
okay now is a giant
is not a local quantity because if i fix
any finite radius
you can't distinguish that there's a
giant or this thing has size square out
of n right
but you might hope that in certain
situations if for each
r you see a ball of radius r which is
not stopping to grow with r
maybe there is actually a giant in your
graph
okay
and that was it and it turns out there
are techniques and it allows us to sort
of
tease apart the local properties of your
graph
and those are usually not enough to
guarantee a giant
plus a global properties
and there are many things so for example
if you want to study random walks on
that because you love rumors and that is
sort of maybe your model for rumors
again you might wonder once it spreads
local
will it spread to the whole graph
and or you may want to say well
if i study it local gnp looks lot of
like like a tree locally
what if i do my statistical physics on
that tree will that actually describe
correctly statistical physics of my
sequence so you can ask all kinds of
questions like that and cutoff can
separate out there may be some
properties for all what you need is this
local notion and there may be other
properties where it's not true where you
need more okay so this will distinguish
us from the dense graphs where once you
had this convergence of these
probability distributions you got a
graph on and once you had the graphene
you could calculate statistical physics
and cuts and you can actually calculate
calculations on these graphs so
in for the dense graphs a lot of
processes on these graphs
are determined once you have conversions
for this local notion of convergence
there are some processes which are
determined
and others which are not
and
i will sort of so i'm doing
unfortunately the boring mars and just
bringing you up to speed to the mass
which we sort of need and which suviq
was
putting under the carpet there somewhere
and jagannee may have sort of now put a
little less under the carpet because she
has that at her proposal
so but i still want to ask you this
question because i think it's important
okay
yes
for that you said for any l or f
function yes that is continuous that's
continuous with respect to
right this aspect
to
be local
okay so what does that mean
that means if two graphs
are similar into that in very loud balls
if
if they are isomorphic and very large
bonds
then the value of the function shouldn't
change too much
and in many cases the only way to prove
that the function is continuous is
actually to show that it doesn't depend
on the ball anymore at all once r is
thick enough
so for example if i ask whether the
component of a random
so i look at the vertex i look at the
component of that vertex i ask whether
it's
bigger or smaller than 500
well you can
convince yourself if you if you're
wearing a bounded degree graph
then to be bigger or not than 500 you
can sort of well once you but actually
you don't even need 400 degrees once you
have gone up to distance 500
you will know whether it's bigger than
500
either you have found 500 vertices
maybe they are much more but anyhow if
you have at least if it has 500
purchases you have either seen them at
smaller distances or you have walked up
to distance 500 and you know that so if
you have walk up to distance 500
499 and you see only
up to 499 right so you see less than 500
vertices and at distance 500 you don't
see a vertex then you know the component
has size smaller than 500
so the question whether
the component
of the root of a graph so
an input here any graph okay fix some gn
you fix this
and now the question whether the
component of that vertex in this graph
has size at least 500
is the local function
so many of the things right and so
and maybe you actually know you have
some function which you can approximate
where you sort of like you could ask is
there a vertex as distance 500 if so i
give it value 1 over 500 or something so
you could
obviously construct continuous functions
that depend on all distances
um
and
but they will actually sort of generally
be generated by the functions which
are just depend on finite volts but this
isn't continuous
you're saying the function is zero and
then a step function at once
it's metric considered continuous
so you are saying that if d log is
uh sufficiently small
then the
f function is closed arbitrarily close
yes
okay you want me to define so
f is continuous
for epsilon x is the data
such that if
local
minus f of that
right so you want this to so if this is
sufficiently small this gets small
okay
good so now let's go to these examples
okay so i choose a random route here
and now it turns out that in this case
the limit the mu is actually
not random it's a deterministic limit
graph okay in that case the limit graph
is just i can take one triangle put the
root in it
and that's a limit graph
it's a rooted triangle
okay so even though you have this
infinite sequence of graphs when you
choose the random root it rely in one of
the triangles
and then you see the triangles and since
we delete the components which are not
of the root that's your limit okay
so that's example one
but you have an example two
in the example two
i just have cd
well in this example z2 and the orange
so you have sort of the origins
so you get just
so here
the limit is an infinite graph
it's rooted
but it's still not random
okay
now it's different in this case okay
because in this case
this probability one half your root sits
here
then you have degree four
and with probability one half it sits
here
and then you have degree eight
so that's certainly different
so
so in example three
with probability one-half
you get
this guy
centered
in the middle of one of these squares
and going off to infinity
okay and in the other case
you get
that's too low
get
this point as your center
okay and here the root has to create
in both cases
in both facts you have an infinite
so in both cases so this is sort of
i don't know how i want to call that zd
face centered
with
this root right
and here you have this root
on the same
c2
space
in 2d match makes no difference whether
it's face centers or cubic centers so
you just add this right so this is an
infinite graph
and with probability one-half it's this
and it's for probably one half a cent
okay so if you are so
um
so for example your function could be
i look at such an infinite graph
i look that's a ball of radius 5
i do percolation on that ball of radius
5
and i ask you whether that component has
size at least three
if that would be your function
well
depending whether you sit if you are
here
the probabilities is sort of smaller
because you only have four connections
to go out one whereas you have eight
here
right so the function on this graph
has some value
on this it has a larger value
and
the expectation with respect to mu
would actually
mix it
okay
so but i'm already sort of talking about
let me there just this is kind of
motivation which we have not quite
formalized but just for motivation okay
so but these examples you should keep in
mind so so far so is it roughly clear
what it means for sequence of finite
graphs to be locally weak convergence
yes okay so in the finite graphs those
were finite graphs with with edge
effects right there were some weird yes
and but the point is that those are a
negligible share of what's going on so
they don't show up right
okay but if your finite graphs would be
if i would have a sequence of finite
graphs this graphs and then
sort of have a line which goes to
infinity
then these effect edge effects will
remain and now it will matter whether
the root is here or here or here
even though maybe then these are make
infinite and just make the edge effect
go away right so you can have a sequence
of graphs which has some edge effects
some of them go away some of them stay
it's all allowed in this game
okay so it allows you to ask questions
you have an arbitrary sequence of graphs
and now you may want to know
on that sequence of graph what's the
probability that if i start to do my
my economic game at the origin what's
the probability that it will reach
equilibrium
in sort of this finite graph and then
you may want to ask what's the limiting
questions and may you want to know is it
enough to know this limit or have you
lost information which were in the
finite graphs which were actually
important for the effect you wanted to
study
so that's exactly sort of the kind of
question you want to study with local
reconvergence they sort of and you
should really keep in mind they're
sometimes useful and sometimes you need
extra conditions
um so now we have to how i'm doing on
time
i have still time
good so now we have to discuss what
happens if your graph itself is random
okay and now things become confusing
okay so let's say and let me first
give you a definition which is a
possible definition
and it's sometimes used but it's not a
useful definition
okay and actually a definition is
actually very defined but that
definition will not be very useful if
you want to prove things
[Music]
okay
if
the n is random
for example gnp
or
right love
d which is d minor law
okay so i have two examples here
um
and for example let me just put two
different examples i can put
here
g and three
but i could also put oh there's no no
three regular infinite letters huh so
maybe it will come six regular
i just thought nice i put the triangular
letters but unfortunately it's not
okay so we could look at g and six or
this graph
okay
and we could sort of study the weak
local limit okay so this is random this
is not right but here we choose a random
route
okay
and
um
as it will turn out even with the
randomness and no matter how you define
randomness
they will have the same weak local limit
and this guy is an expander and this one
is not
and they in many ways behave totally
different but they will have the same
local limit
so but just keep these examples in mind
okay so if gn is random i define
en is
locally
deeply
urgent
only if i have that
again for all for
expectation
and now this is
disrespect
to
the random north success of gn
and
xn uniformly at random
in the vertices in gn
okay
of f
of
the random root and g n
converges
to the expectation with respect to sum
so if there exists
a measure mu
and actually i will call it mu bar
such that this converges
question
uh this shouldn't be this
uh i i don't care in which order it's
expectation okay
yeah so gn is given now gn is random
it's a three regular random graph right
then you choose a random root right
and but you could also first choose a
random number from one up to n and then
form your gn right so in that case but
you could imagine that then the curve
even has a random number of vertices and
if so i have to first choose
gn randomly and then choose a random
root in it and then i take expectations
with that to both
and then i ask whether this converges
okay
now
this actually if you really think about
it okay
um
i can tell you why it's sort of not a
good enough notion it guarantees you
convergence of first moments
and
first moments will not give you
concentration
now you might have said wait a second so
that's actually an issue here already
why would that ever be useful this is
also a first moment condition only right
it just first moment with respect to the
random route
okay
and so you might actually worry how
useful this is
because again it's only a first moment
but actually this one
happens to be
so this is your standard notion of
the convergence with respect to this
topology
and that's just how we convergence
defined you take expectations with
respect to continuous functions and
that's sometimes quite useful okay
you
you wouldn't want to ask much more here
because then you would certainly not
have many examples which are at all
convergent okay this is sort of pretty
much
for these local notions all you can ask
for
and so it turns out okay so we can ask
this okay but we can formulate a
different condition
so if i okay so if i start if i this
would be my definition okay
and so we would have used this
definition of local weak convergence
then actually theorem would have been
false
so yes
can you restate this
weak convergence definition in terms of
convergence and distribution
i sort of probably knew that at some
point
for every
fixed finite to the graph h
oh any questions are
probability that the ball of the first
graph is is
but this is not the notion of
convergence in distribution
which
is
because that would mean the distribution
function
do you remember
there is
to me this looks like
you see this it is
what so you want that the distribution
you see this is not
this just says that the expectation of f
of this this is not the same as saying
that the distribution of this
converges to the distribution of this
because actually
well that's just not true because the
distribution of this does often not
converge to this notion of that
um
you sort of right i mean you have to
somehow bring in your local
you you have to sort of somehow use the
d local right
yes that's what i'm thinking
right but yours what you define is not
convergence in distribution
okay so there is notion of convergence
which is in probability in distribution
um
almost surely there are many versions of
um
and um
so this is and this is weak convergence
is still another notion of convergence
and depending on your situation there
are sort of different notions so i mean
peter is probably our expert is it is
that the same as converging distribution
well the question is like what
distribution do you want to converge
right the
it's like this is somehow
frustratingly less useful for inference
than
fitting a stochastic block model because
you don't just have a summary object
it's more like somehow more descriptive
and and basically the
split in the randomness that you get by
drawing roughly random and drawing from
the graph
that somehow splits randomness into two
big parts
and here you're splitting off almost
nothing in a sense because you first
have to generate the entire graph and
then you randomly
so i will just tell you so there will be
three notions okay
and
so this is one and this one turns out to
be just not useful okay and to say in
distribution as we said we would have to
talk which distribution and that will
actually that's exactly the confusion
now the question is with respect to this
or with respect to this i mean you could
just say okay for example do i need the
distribution of g n to converge well
what does that mean right
or do i need the distribution of this
rooted random object to converge i will
and
that is actually not the same it's sort
of so it's um
so anyhow it's
anyhow i define it locally conversions
which means that if you integrate with
respect to a continuous bound functions
those converge
okay so that's weak convergence it's not
weak star convergence really traditional
definition of the convergence
improvements
okay
so
and if you have delta functions in your
life right you sort of you always have
that the week here meaning that weakest
ever possible among all the converters
notions
look this one okay
the whole community defined local league
conversions like that okay yeah i just
started that business so i actually
might prefer to just call this benjamin
conversions but the
community calls it local weak
convergence which means with respect to
the local metric
it's a traditional notion of weak
conversions so it's perfectly fine for
protest okay
and maybe it's not fine for statistician
or somebody who wants to do machine
learning also whatever it's a definition
and it's actually not a useful one
even though some people
so
this is just a nice definition if the
sequence of graphs is more random but if
the sequence of graphs itself is random
this is
turned out not to be a useful definition
okay
so what is this issue okay so the issue
is that if i
look at sort of the limit of n goes to
infinity
of e
let me now just choose a random
performance
now i calculate
a function which depends
on the random root
and the random graph
but this object
is just still a random quantity
and
and that is sort of the thing we really
have to worry about for example you have
a graph okay let's you do do percolation
on it okay and now you ask
is there
what is the probability that
that a ball of radius r
has
sort of
sees at least 500 vertices and r is 20.
okay
so
if your graph is random
this is a random quantity
and if you just but if for example your
graph is this probability half
a union of disjoints
six regular graphs
and with probability half this hexagon
lattice
okay
then you will never get with probability
one convergence of the size of the giant
because in one of them the giant will be
this small
six regular graph and in the other one
the giant will become
a giant okay
but in expectation
you will not see the difference
up to that distance right so
so there will be
notions of graphs
i can't for example if i take
i have a
sequence of graph which converges
i take two copies of it
when you choose a random root let's say
they have the same size which per half
it sits in one of them is probably half
it sits in the other
since they are the same graph i may as
well just say okay i have a random root
in this one graph and the limit is some
limit
locally
but in one case
the giant component will be half the
size of the other okay
and this will be totally hidden in these
expectations if i take here also the
expectation respect to the randomness of
the graph
okay so
so i don't want to take that so this is
a random quantity
and we could for example instead of
asking takes expected so this is a
random quantity even in the limit so and
now what is the limit of a random
quantity i haven't even defined that for
you okay but this will well the limit of
a random quantity could now be
in distribution in probability in
almost surely
okay
and so
i think the convergence of this object
in distribution
is probably the same as the weekly log
conversions
okay so to your
question
but we will not be interested in that
anymore if the expectation of this
converges i will just call it
locally weekly conversion so now
i will can sort of say okay what if this
converges
in probability
okay
this respect to let me express with
respect to the randomness of your random
so
this was random with the random root and
gn
now i integrate out okay so let me write
this expectancy this is one over v of g
n
sum over x
in v of g n
f of
x
and g n
so this is clearly if gn is not random
not the random pointed here i have
integrated out the randomness with
respect to the root
and now this this has still this
randomness
and now i can ask that this converges in
probability
to mu of
f of
sigma and g
and this graph is drawn from this
distribution
okay
or i could ask that this converges
almost surely
with respect to
v of g n
assuming i have coupled all the gns just
for the expansion
um
so
these are two different notions
okay
and both are actually useful
okay
because if you for example study
percolation and you have all the other
conditions which he has
and you actually so if you use his
theorem with this definition of local
weak convergence
then actually his theorem is false
okay because he actually has then you
can prove maybe that the expectation of
the giant
is something i know even that doesn't
work so you just can't so it just is not
useful if you have this condition okay
then actually if this converges in
distribution then the second moment of
this guy will also converge
and then you can do second moment
arguments and prove the concentration of
the things here and in the end are
really interested in
so
having convergence in probability of
this object
is useful
convergence almost surely of this object
is also useful
having local weak convergence of this
object
is in most cases useless
unless your sequence itself is
non-random in which case they're all the
same
okay so these two
so these are called
and i'm using
the notation of hofstadt
graphs
is it called random graphs it's called
large graphs
random
graphs complex networks
and it's really important you can sort
of make tons of mistakes in this area
proving theorems which are just not true
if you don't are not aware of this
subtlety okay so these are called
local conversions
in probability
or
local convergence
almost surely
okay
for the two versions
okay
and so if you want to prove and so for
example there's an interesting fact
which i will just tell you if you have a
sequence of random graphs
which is locally weak converging in
probability and you do percolation on it
then the percolated graphs are also
convergence
locally weakened probability
okay
and that gives you
second moments for free as such
so this turns out to be super useful
once you have proven that your sequence
is convergent so in many i mean you have
to do the mask to see but in many
applications it will essentially give
you concentration with respect to the
randomness of these graphs
for free
okay
and if you do this definition it just
gives you nothing
so well it gives you some expectations
but often you want you're interested in
the expectation of some global object
and just because you have expectations
of local object doesn't mean you will
get expectation of the global object but
if you have sort of concentration for
this local objects let's say you had
almost surely that you can use this
theorem because you have almost surely
and then you can actually then conclude
something in the end about the giant
and also about the expectation of
subject okay
so so that i really
this is sort of more important than
anything else i want to say to get
really across that this
this difference
okay
um
so are there questions about these
definitions i think you should sort of
to see how it really works maybe i don't
know whether you will see gigan do you
think they will see in your talk a
little how this stuff works well i
certainly should see how it's useful
so let me tell you for example an
example if i know a sequence is located
no that's
zero is actually too much
okay i just want to tell you theorem
which holds but it's actually it's true
general so
i wanted to say if you have a sequence
which is
locally converged in probability
you will know that two random vertices
that their distance must go to infinity
that actually happens to be true in that
notion
okay so that's one of the few useful
results which actually hold
in this general setting
um but
um
because well if something goes to zero
and expectation goes to zero and
probability so it's always certain
things which are useful but in most
cases
you
and the way you prove this usually okay
is we just choose
two random vertices in the graph
and then prove
that the expectation of the product
of these functions converges to the
expectation
squared of the original thing
and that is how you write because now
you have a random quantity how do i
prove it converges in probability so you
do a first and second moment thing on
that
in the very beginning for your graph
sequence
and then for many of the questions
you're interested you don't have to
worry about concentration anymore so
that's why this is a very nice technique
and ramco in his book where he really
wanted to apply it to studying the giant
really worked out these differences
which for the probably is two sort of
sound diseases in a very abstract
setting and they use the symmetry of the
limit object and then they prove some
very nice general theorems
they don't even see
that there is this difference because
they have these nice serums which i
could all probably prove for the other
version too and then actually
if you write a paper where you do that
careful they don't read it careful and
they say your paper has a mistake
because i have a counter example and
that's because they never think about
this difference and that is the counter
example would be there if you use one
definition not in the ass
so it's so when you actually want to do
applications of that these notions are
really
different and i think it's really amco
should be really credited for
really pushing that difference
for example we showed for
we a while ago showed that the
preferential attachment graph converges
locally weekly
okay and then we claimed some theorems
okay that i said but actually
this now it turns out that our proof
could immediately use to also prove
that version
but we didn't do it right and now we
claimed some convergence of power laws
and things like that so strictly
speaking this paper is wrong
okay
which i hate to admit because i like
finding mistakes in other people's paper
not in my own
and actually i like to find them myself
but anyhow
actually i did find it myself we found
it together
um
so and it's easy to repair because but
so in many in some cases easy to repair
and you just
do your second moment bound to prove the
convergence in other cases it's actually
not easy repair and you just have a
theorem which is false okay
yes so uh this one if you have this
condition without the probability
convergence so can you at least
conclude that expectation is positive
expected
of the joint yes not the probability
convergence that no i don't even think
such forms
so
this condition would give you that
expected number of
uh what is the components of life
side larger than k proportion of that
converges in expectation yes
the expectation of this perspective and
what
but i mean i was just wondering if there
are counter examples
i mean
i think so because i could imagine sort
of mixing in some graphs or sizes
and stuff where in expectation it
doesn't show up and you sort of
but it's not just probability one
so i actually think i mean
truth of the matter is so either you're
sort of a real mathematician and you
want to prove a general scene and then
you may make mistakes if you do that
in real life you have very good
intuitions and even though you may only
prove that
your intuition tells you all this thing
is probably almost truly
and maybe you can't prove almost sure
because that's very hard to prove
and then i think it's a very nice of
this thing but often when you're just
willing to do more work you can
calculate the second one
so you should be if you can prove
this version and the other one is not
true
something very weird is going on but i'm
not sure if your random graphs are spin
glasses and things like that i mean
there may be situations where this
delicate i mean we know from statistical
physics there are situations where
it's just not true you can take
expectations okay and this is an example
where at least see it so anyhow this is
um
the general setup so let me just
mention the symmetry and i will not do
any of the other stuff because i think
this is really abstract well maybe i
will spend one for the slide but so what
is the symmetry so assume you have this
limit okay are there any symmetries okay
it's not very clear right if your
original graph had a symmetry maybe that
symmetry is there right if your original
graph had
all degrees are three that's the
symmetry but it will be true in the
limit okay but that's not what i'm
talking about i'm talking about
exchangeability or some symmetry like
that so there's one symmetry
which comes from the fact that choose a
random route in my graph originally
now imagine looking at the neighbor of
that random route
okay so that neighborhood can't be
arbitrary
okay so for example
if i choose the neighbor of a random
root
that neighbor can't have degree zero
so i could have a sequence so i could
have a graph
okay so this is my graph
so with probability one quarter i see an
isolated vertex
so
the limit of that is this probability
one quarter
i get
this and this probability one quarter
but three quarters
i get a rooted track
okay
now if i choose a random neighbor of my
thing here
that random neighbor will have degrees
3.
so if i look at so the distribution of
this guy can't be so the distribution of
a random neighbor of the root can't be
arbitrary in particular it must degree
larger than one even though the root
doesn't have degree so
the question is are the two related in
some reasonable way
and the answer is yes because in the
finite graph if you think about it the
probability of choosing a random
neighbor of a random root is just
choosing probability proportional to
degree
so in other words the limit must be such
that if i look at my distribution on
infinite graphs
i choose one i take the root
now i look at the distribution i get of
the graph seen from a random neighbor of
the boot still infinite
then this distribution must be the same
as my original distribution reweighted
by the random degree of the root i'm
currently
seeing yes
and so this is called uh
what
what is it
i always forget the word i'm sort of not
um
thank you
so it's called unimodularity
okay so every limit object must be
unimodal
it's a question that's our every union
model a random graph
actually can be
obtained as a limit is all
sorry what's the definition of universal
just this thing you have an infinite
random graph
rooted
and if you look at the distribution of
the graph obtained from that by taking a
random root of the neighbor that gives
you a different distribution i mean it's
the same infinite graph but it's a
different random rooted graph
and you should get that distribution by
just
choosing your vertex according to the
degree right so
the probability
that
g of
sigma
okay so i take
so i define
g star
sigma g star okay
i define it by choose
sigma
prime and g from mu
then
choose
sigma
uniformly
from its neighbors
prime
and
now look at the rooted random graph
where rooted at sigma okay
so this is some distribution mu star
which is different
and the claim is mu star
of
mu star of let's say i want to look at
some ball of radius r around the origin
f okay so this is equal to mu
of
br of sigma e
times the degree of the root in vr
whereas this being equal to some graph h
so the degree of the root in h
normalized
okay so that's a very
yes
i know there is a very different view
which is mass transport on your graph
huh
i mean i mean the
lines of trump kind of so basically
you think about doing simple random walk
on your graph and looking at the scenery
that you occur
that remains very basic
so it's kind of like stationarity but
it's kind of a messed up stationarity
because the shifts that you're allowed
to make depend on the instance
on the realization
so so that's our original definition by
[Music]
so there's also another one where you
can sort of talk about transporting mass
in your graph
and this is essentially doing that in
one step and what you can do
this random walk one i'm sort of
astonished that it's not originally
invented in the friend because they
actually studied random walks
and thought that says about the random
walks on the origin
just think about scenery i think right
here looking at triangulation whereas
the more so in this literature of the
last five to ten years
this has been used a lot to study
population
for us
and it has in the end simplified some of
the existing proofs of the giant
goes in the literature as is percolation
look
which is the question once you know sort
of you have a local limit it's going to
have two graph sequences if they have
the same weak global limit do they have
the same pc do they have the same size
of the giant questions
okay
i think i'm out of time almost so let me
just put up
a little
i would like some screen for one minute
hello
is it back print
so it turns out okay so we can again
define these different notions of
conversions
and
if you don't have bounded degrees
you have to modify them a lot so let me
just for the purpose of this talk not
discuss it and it turns out that this
one is again equivalent
okay
you just have to normalize your
subgraphs correctly so here now you can
normalize by one over n as you suggested
neither you are you one of the two guys
in yellow shirts suggested to normalize
different
you can also define convergence of cuts
and free energies you again just divide
by n instead of n squared
and but it's not true anymore that the
two that these things are equivalent i
will not walk through all the counter
examples
so what you have actually is
that if you have so this is sort of i
call it here left convergence because
you test again your graph from the left
so this
local reconvergent for a non-random
graph and the local convergence in
probability and things like that so but
let's say we wear a deterministic graph
this does not imply convergence of
statistical physics
it does imply statistical convergence of
high temperature statistical physics
because high temperature statistic
physics is really local
but it does not imply for example
convergence of oh i call these quotients
i should have said motivate cuts
quotient is an even generalization of
that or a different framing so it does
not apply convergence of multi-way cuts
and there are easy examples you take
a d regular
random graph and a d regular bipartite
random graph their cuts their max cut
differ by a factor of two essentially
and
but they have the same weak local limit
okay so this does not imply the same
card so it doesn't imply global
properties
on the other hand
it so but if you have right conversions
you have in particular high temperature
high conversions and for high
temperatures actually these two are
equivalent okay because high temperature
physics to some extent if i have high
temperature physics for all possible
models
i see sort of the local interaction
which means i see the local graph sort
of distance one and then if i expand my
things out further interactions
interactions will go on and on and on
and so you have this direction
and together with david garmanic who
seems i don't see him here we actually
came up with a notion which is
some notion of large deviations which
actually implies all three
okay
um but that is maybe not that important
i think it's actually more important to
just remember that
and this is again the same thing so if
you have this local convergence and you
have an extra condition for statistical
physics at high temperature
then it's useful
in general
it's not because you can come up with
counter examples that look globally
different and locally are the same and
if you're whatever you do test globality
and it always depends on what global and
local means for percolation it's for
pollution epidemics at one thing it
turns out that you need an additional
expanders
for
statistical physics expander is not the
issue
for cuts
that's also not the issue it's the issue
whether you're for example with your but
whether you're too color it depends if
you take a torus of even or odd side
lengths
so they're very different for two
colorings
and but they have totally same log weak
limit so that and that both are not
expanders so it's not always expanders
okay so and it depends on sparse graphs
are just very complicated and sort of a
lot of complexity theory uses sparse
graphs for counter examples and things
like that and so we can't really expect
that there is sort of this global theory
of sparse graph convergence which
answers all questions
you have to sort of work
and
jager naval has done a lot of work
and she will present some of
how we can actually use this stuff this
afternoon
speakers have prepared excellent slides
will all these slides available because
it will be very educational
so send them to elizabeth and she will
annotate your talk this year
thanks
thanks
because i will see you yesterday
because i guess we have the videos but
video slides
for some reason
oh my
because all my jokes are so dumb so you
don't want to hear them
so it's nice to have the slides i i
sometimes like to just look through
slides and not
i was saying the two of us is generation
who wants to read slides and not watch
me well my talk isn't even going to be
recorded so
oh it's not recorded
or you didn't get microsoft permission
to
have been recorded i have permission i
just want to
be we can create a different
[Music]
in
atmosphere
yeah we should send the warning
yeah
[Music]